each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
it's a great pleasure to introduce this
afternoon IBM fellow Grady Booch of
course many of you know Grady's work
familiar with it he's been devoting his
life to the development of software and
object-oriented design and analysis he
was a chief scientist at rationale from
its beginning rational Software
Corporation from its founding in
nineteen eighty-one and he continues to
be the chief scientist through the
acquisition of rational by IBM gravy of
course has done many many different
things in the in the object-oriented
software design community but one of the
great contributions as his work as a
founding as a fundamental author of the
unified modeling language uml and of
course the many books that he's written
many of us I'm sure familiar with the
seminal object-oriented analysis with
applications that he wrote and he's also
written the UML user's guide and many
many papers so this afternoon grade is
gonna be talking about the promised
limits the beauty of software Grady's
been working in this field so many years
he's got many deep insights and I'm very
happy that he's going to share them with
us today so please welcome Grady Booch
so I guess the first thing you need to
say is my comments are mine not
necessarily that of IBM or anybody
living or dead or those kinds of things
because if you think about it it's kind
of strange here I am an IBM or amidst
you using actually a Macintosh but
that's another story
I mostly do that to annoy the hell out
of IBM management I think they made me a
fellow largely because I'm unmanageable
and as a fellow there there are
basically three things I'm doing these
days the nice thing about being what I
in what I do in the company is that I
have lots of degrees of freedom to
pursue what I find interesting for the
company and the primary two things that
I'm spending time on are in the area of
software architecture the next book I'm
working on is a handbook of software
architecture some of you may have
visited my website where my intent is to
take a look at a hundred different
seminal systems around the world and
simply document their architecture if
you're a civil engineer you learned by
studying the works of great other civil
engineers and designers and architects
and in software however we have no such
reference and therefore most people
learn their systems because of simply
discovering it through tribal memory
they'll work up in a particular area
they'll study it for a while they'll
grow up inside it but often have no
insights into other ways to design
systems so I'm looking at everything
from in fact latest archaeological digs
have been for the NASA JPL Pathfinder
been spending time with the London
Underground folks symbian the operating
system for cell phones and later today
the primary reason here I'm on the
campus is to spend a little bit of time
with the word team because I'd like to
document their architecture in so far as
allowed me to do so I spend time in the
past few months with the folks at
photoshop photoshop team ebay amazon you
name and it's sort of across the board
and i've learned some things along the
way deed that's why i write books
primarily to learn there's so much i
know i don't know right now the second
thing where I'm spending a lot of my
time is in the area of collaboration so
if you happen to be in Second Life go
visit me as a lean theist that's my
avatar name where we're doing some some
research in the areas of what can one do
in virtual worlds to support temporal
and geographically distributed
development we think there are some
interesting opportunities there so those
two areas of the primary places where
I'm spending my time the third that's
worthy of mentioning here
is that in rational I work with our CTO
a guy named Martinelli to manage our
research program with IBM Research and
Watson in China and India and other
places we actually had some interesting
discussions this morning on some
interesting things you guys are up to
and and shared a little bit about some
of the things we're up to as well if you
think about it you know we we all are
doing some common things here we're all
trying to fight the evils in the world
of complexity and apathy and Google and
all the other did I say that yes I did
not necessarily saying they're evil but
there's certainly a worthy worthy
opponent in this marketplace and that's
a good thing we like having opponents
that are that are worthy of fighting and
helps make us all better I think so
earlier this year I was invited by the
british computer society to give a
lecture the turing lecture in England
not the Turing award but this is the
Turing lecturer named after of course
Alan Turing himself in the University of
Manchester and basically it was taking a
look at what i see happening in the
world and of software in the coming
decades my focus inside rational and it
continues to be inside IBM rational and
for the software group is worrying about
the next five to ten years and so that's
why I'm doing the two things I'm doing
as well as a variety of other activities
that make me look out into what's
possible so in the hour or so we have
here i'm going to talk for a while we'll
have time for questions at the end along
the way if you have any questions or if
i say something that offends you or
makes you stand up and want to throw
things at me go ahead and ask me
questions then and we'll try to address
it at that point but i take to take a
look at what i have learned over
spending time with thousands of projects
what makes it difficult for us to take
our notion of the vision and turn that
into naked running code these are the
limits of software and yet at the same
time there's so much that we think we
can do with software we're going to look
beyond however limited and also take a
look at what software might do for us
but then there's a third aspect and this
comes about primarily because of the
work I've done in the architecture side
as well as the academic community it's
the issues of how do I demonstrate
the beauty of the software we have
produced we have created artifacts as a
community of incredible complexity and
yet how do we share the beauty we have
there in so we can inspire the
generations after us to go off and build
these kinds of things as well too many
times I've had colleagues come up to me
and say I would never want to have my
son or daughter or dog or cat go into
the software field it's just a terrible
place to be because it's going to be
outsourced there's no fun anymore you
know all the cool stuffs done and I just
want to throttle them by the neck and
say well no this is not so there is
still lots of really cool things to be
done here there are lots of
opportunities for innovation innovation
will never be outsourced and there are
lots of opportunity to craft truly
wonderful things and the things we
produce among other things I spend time
with the Computer History Museum in the
Bay Area and a few years ago I went to
their board of trustees and convince
them that they should also become a
Museum of software not just hardware
it's fun to look at the old bits of
hardware and that's really interesting
but if you think about the trajectory of
things the next generation of people
we're going to look at hardware or
they're going to need to have
microscopes to basically look at the
hardware because it's going to be
uninteresting and so they need to make a
shift to what I think is the real
fundamental value of our industry which
is not just the machines upon which
these run these are commodities largely
but now rather the software that we have
created as an industry and so we're
trying to preserve things such as the
early Fortran compilers some of the not
just the languages but also some of the
early applications we track down for
example the source code to mac paint
which it's a beautiful piece of code it
truly is Apple has not let us release it
to the world because obviously it's so
important to the bottom line of Apple
and we destroy their stock shareholder
value if we released it but I've looked
at and it's it's a beautiful piece of
code of it doing similar things with
with other companies and indeed wherever
I can hear i'm urging the microsoft is
to say go save the source code to word
and to windows and all these things
because
a hundred years from now you know bills
not going to care your lawyers might but
Bill's not going to care and you'd
certainly want to preserve this stuff
for future generations it would be a
shame if if you as a company had
basically let all that stuff evaporate
so you know think about putting that in
a public escrow or something so that we
can get to it eventually as I was trying
to track down the source code for the
IBM 360 operating system I was amused to
discover that IBM has lost a copy of it
so IBM itself no longer has the source
so I'm going to academic places and see
if we can track it down so anyway that's
what keeps me busy his Burnitz true
Strip has observed our civilization runs
on software but he's an insider and so
he's going to give us a little bit
skewed view of what software offers for
us let's look at somebody radically
different in particular the former
president of poland i guess it was yeah
in which he observed this is upon his
first visit to Western Europe we said
you guys have so much why can't you use
your computers and other things for the
search for love he's not talking about
match.com or something like this but but
I think what he was pointing out is that
in the end the value of what we do is a
community can be measured in so far as
it touches the human spirit so it's
where you're going to find a technical
lecture in which one of the first things
that comes out of your lecturers mouth
is about the importance or the
relationship of software and love and
software and beauty that indeed it is
there the things we have created our
wonderfully complex their incredible
creations and yet in the end insofar as
they change the way the world works
that's I think ultimately where it's a
value is and what he's pointing out is
there's so much more that can be done to
that end I would observe that they're
great things that we know that software
has done for us and this is why it's
such a privilege to be a software
developer they can amplify human
intelligence they confuse coordinate
classify analyze information but at the
same time we know there are limits
because we know that
for intensive systems can't replace
human judgment a few about a year or so
ago I was approached by some of the
folks at Homeland Security and they said
we've got this really cool idea we know
that first you know that's a warning
flag Oh a government official with a
cool idea and my BS meter pegged so they
pointed out that in the government we've
got all these silos we've got social
security information and tax records and
all these retirement kind of things and
what they wanted to do was to go
searching across them looking for
patterns of really bad behavior so in
the end they literally said we'd like to
cut across and find the bag bad guys and
automatically produce a warrant for
their arrest now
I politely suggested that what they
would wish to do maybe technically
feasible but I had a few problems in
terms of violation of my rights as a
human being for so doing and so we know
that there are some things that we can
do we probably shouldn't do because
these are systems for which the presence
of human judgment is certainly still a
very valuable thing we also know that
there are limits in the sense that we
can't create new semantics we can't
create new knowledge we can look at it
in different ways perhaps through our
automated systems but but ultimately
there are some things that our software
systems cannot do as well as should not
do so to put it another way not
everything we want to build can be built
there are some fundamental limits and
it's also the case and not everything we
want to build perhaps should be built
and these are the the more social and
moral kinds of limits it is also the
case that is alluded to there's they're
still tremendous opportunity for
exposing the beauty in our software
systems dick Gabriel has written some
delightful papers to this end his his
less is more paper I think that's the
title of it or good enough software is
basically his theme is saying that you
know sometimes in our field we search
for absolute precision and perfection
but there is no such thing but rather
what we should search for is elegance
and beauty and simplicity because we
know when we've got to that point we
probably produce something that's very
real invaluable Buckminster Fuller the
architect has often observed or had
often observe that he doesn't worry
about beauty in building buildings but
he knows that when he has done if the
thing is created is not beautiful than
he's failed and yet it's a very
difficult thing to measure how do we in
software measure beauty well we do it
through simplicity and elegance and
cleverness but it's difficult to get a
true handle upon what that thing is I
guess the conundrum with this however is
that while we are building things with
incredible complexity most of the world
doesn't seen it doesn't see it at all so
a little bit of a guessing game here how
many lines of code do you think were
written in the world last year
will include visual basic in that talent
but take a wag a trillion actually a
little too high 1 billion a little too
low so you now you can apply a binary
search the problem 10 billion 10 billion
a little bit low it's about 33 billion
according to my back-of-the-envelope
calculation how do I get that well there
are about 15 million software
professionals worldwide surprisingly as
I discovered when I came into IBM not
every manager codes wow what a shock so
of course all of you do here right all
the managers code so
back-of-the-envelope calculation says oh
maybe twenty to thirty percent of those
professionals actually cut code for a
living and of those people that cut code
on the average it's somewhere around you
know five to ten thousand lines of debug
code per person per year that's also an
average looks kind of small but remember
we're looking at an average we know that
the bell curve is skewed that there are
people who just do outrageously amazing
things and you want to treat these
people really well and you know pay them
lots of money or do whatever it is to
keep them around multiply those together
and you get around thirty three billion
lines in neuro modified code per year
but if you cumulative Lee added up over
the years since about 45 or so when the
first high order programming languages
begin to emerge truly began to emerge it
brings us to about a trillion lines of
code and so a trillion lines of code
that we as an industry have built over
the years that's an amazing number which
represents the the the output of a very
vibrant community and it's at trillion
lines of code that we have used to
change the world change the way that
people work in the world the way that
civilizations interact with one another
that's tremendous leverage from that
kind of source code and yet as as the
the average person will realize we
desire to make that code and all the
software utterly invisible insofar as
the bones of our implementation stick
through we've actually failed because
for the average user it should be
seamless an eBay story here ebays got
most of their stuff all their servers
sort of living in one space on the west
coast or desiring now too
put things across to Europe and Asia and
yet for the average user of eBay which
is think your grandmother that's sort of
the average user of ebay they could care
less about all the stuff that's below
the surface and they have an assumption
of a particular behavior that eBay
offers now they post something for sale
they go to another page and poof it's
there automatically immediately and yet
if you start figuring out how to divide
things up across literally the
collateral to the globe then getting
that same kind of quick behavior is not
so easy so the one of the difficulties
for them is how do you give the illusion
of simplicity in the face of incredible
complexity below the surface so your
grandmother types are actually hidden
from all this kind of stuff that's a
real challenge for them and it's
something we all strive to do of course
that conundrum leads me to observe that
in our world there are another a number
of other conundrums that we have to face
now this is going to diverge into an
area that we often don't think about as
developers and you guys are hardcore
researchers you're down there in the
bits you're exploring some very
fascinating things but ultimately I want
to urge you to pop your head up every
now and then realize that the things we
do have ethical and moral implications
to them for example we know that the
presence of the web has utterly changed
the way the individuals collaborate and
businesses work with one another and yet
at the same time this is creating an
environment where terrorists other folks
can work together unimpeded in second
life for example I've heard stories that
some of the government's intelligence
agencies are really worried about things
like virtual worlds because nowadays you
find a spy he does he or she you know
dropped some stuff in a physical site to
exchange information well the web's made
it a little bit more difficult to track
these folks down but now imagine I have
a virtual world where somebody from some
other part of the world can login as
some anonymous character actually drop
some information some place in the
virtual world so that some other bad guy
or bad woman can pick
up how do you protect against that and
the answer is well you can't i'm not
sure you even should but nonetheless it
creates all sorts of dilemmas for for
folks that care about such a things
they've worried ineffective the changing
nature of war not just being in the
physical way but truly cyber kind of
warfare it's also the case the web has
provided unprecedented mechanisms for
social networking this gives me the
opportunity to show Britney Spears is
myspace page please this is the excuse I
gave my wife when I was cutting and
pasting this page but at the same time
the web also creates an incredible place
for the exploitation of children and
fraud and other theft that how do you
protect against it's also the case that
software intensive systems permit
real-time and distributed access to
information got here a little picture of
a just a weather station you can buy
this thing off the shelf you know kind
of plug it in and all of a sudden I now
make the local weather available to
anywhere in the world and yet at the
same time they can erode personal
privacy I I gave this first when I was
in London and it was particularly
poignant because london in of all the
cities in the world is the one that has
the highest concentration of cameras
throughout the city than any other place
and there's a tremendous amount of money
that the UK government is spending on
facial recognition so in the end game is
well gee wouldn't it be interesting if i
can identify a bad person however i may
characterize bad i find them in a
certain place and even though you know
they're not this really doing anything
wrong i can track them wherever they
might go and i have the technology to do
this can I do so is it a good thing is
it a bad thing well how do you weigh off
the the rights of the individual for the
rights of all hard to say it's also the
case that email and other mechanisms
have changed the velocity of information
and yet there's a downside to this as
well historians tell me that this is
threatening our preservation of history
there's a lot of work that DARPA is
doing right now in terms of preservation
or rather the digitization of
lot of government records we had the
what missing nine minutes during during
Nixon's era and now we have the missing
emails during the current administration
email doesn't just disappear you know
truly doesn't it may be hard to find but
it just doesn't go away and yet if you
look at historians who have surveyed you
know the last multiple decades in the
centuries before that there have been
lots of written artifacts that we can go
back to and say well this is sort of
what life was like this is what this
person's life was like how do we do this
now if I'm two or three generations
hints and all of a sudden we have no way
to look at a JPEG format because we've
invalidated that format this is one of
the things the Computer History Museum
is trying to preserve the ability to
read formats for lots of things there
are tapes upon tapes of data that nASA
has for early missions and these things
are not only eroding physically but we
often have no machines to read those
tapes anymore nor do we have the
protocols for even decoding what those
files are and it may seem funny now but
will and I know the folks in
Massachusetts have been worried about
this will dot docx formats be available
you know a thousand years from now will
we be able to read these kinds of things
and historians worry about this kind of
stuff it's also the case that software
intensive systems have created new forms
of artistic instruction I've got here a
snapshot of a synthesizer just a pure
software synthesizer of course the
downside of it is is multiple we have
enabled through software intensive
systems to allow musicians with
absolutely no talent whatsoever to to
make lots of money and this reminds me
of Britney again but let's not talk
about her and yet at the same time this
is of course what's utterly annoying
most of the the major media companies
right now they simply don't know how to
deal with this kind of stuff and of
course is in the midst of all the news
how do you weigh these off it's also the
case that software intensive systems
have enabled an accelerated scientific
research that's
cool I've had some interesting
conversations with dr. craig venter the
gentleman who in sort of in parallel and
competition with the National Institute
of Health decode of the human genome and
yet at the same time you know there's
some amazing things happening because of
software intensive systems in the
medical fields it's also the case that
through software we're now able to build
weapons that kill people a lot faster
than they used to and kill more people
along the way through software intensive
things the work of the Army's future
combat system to really sort of bring
every individual soldier to be an IP
node there are some amazing things you
can do if you make that happen imagine
hacking a soldier well it it's also the
case that software is certainly a part
of the very fabric of our civilization
and insofar as it is weaving its way
into the dark spaces and becoming more
and more invisible to others the problem
is that the complexity of what we're
building is growing exponentially and so
our ability as an industry to just keep
our arms around all the stuff we're
doing and to deal with the potential
interactions of systems of systems over
which we have no control of some of
those systems it's absolutely
frightening I've done archaeological
digs of the northeastern power grid and
its really very scary if you think about
it because many of the folks who run the
power grid really throughout the whole
country are doing with systems that are
very very fragile indeed this is not
only just the power generation but also
the power transmission and it's not just
the security of these systems and you
can find easily if you look a little bit
hard to see a number of unsecured
devices of those networks what if
somebody were to get in sort of bring
down New York City this would not be a
good thing but also it's the problem of
how these things work together one
another they're very chaotic systems
they're very fragile loosely coupled
systems and yet no one has really
planned them across the grid for the
entire United States and so the fact
that they work as well
they do is owing to a lot of good luck
for one and the fact that these systems
are so resilient but as we begin to draw
more and more from them than the
opportunity for these systems to fail in
catastrophic ways because of software
problems underneath them increases
exponentially and of course if that
happens and lawyers get involved and
then all the fun gets sucked out of the
air for us there are no lawyers here I
don't know if you have any lawyers on
your research staff I mean the whole
issue of copyright law is just a fast
anyone Wow don't get me started on that
one in preparation for this work for the
british computer society i went back and
took a look at Alan Turing's life
himself and he truly was an enigma to
use the name of his his biography was
just an amazing fellow he observed that
in terms of what he saw the future of
software to be and remember he was a
mathematician he sort of did so many
different things but this is about 50
years ago and so what he was saying then
is kind of the present now he was
observing this notion of what today we
would call the Turing test now he never
called with the Turing test it was
actually named that by alfred by clark
in 2001 a Space Odyssey so that's where
it came from and the whole thing about
about how so Turing was pointing out
something that was an old Victorian game
a game in which you would put people in
two different rooms and you communicate
with them the letters or whatever and
the part of the idea of the parlor game
was to figure out is this person a man
or a woman and he extended to then say
well can I do that same kind of thing in
not just a man or a woman but also a
computer and his prediction was that
we'd be able to do that in about 50
years funny story about him to that he
apparently was telling this story to
somebody inside AT&T or bell labs at the
time he was in the Bell Labs laboratory
and somebody asked him about this he
said oh I don't mean to simulate a great
intelligence of genius I just want to
simulate a mediocre mind someone like
the president of 80 and
deathly silence so so here we are
simulating the intelligence of the
mediocre mind well enough about George
Bush but that's me again not IBM don't
worry he also observed he also observed
that there are indeed limits in his
limits that he saw primarily came from
from his mathematical foundations he
realized this notion of computability
which said that well if it's not
computable then it's something that
we're not going to be able to do in
software so that's the ultimate limit
for him and yet as I look at the problem
I think that's maybe the fundamental
limit but there are lots of other things
that make it difficult for us to take
our vision and turn that into reality
Turing also observed the beauty in
software and he saw from a mathematical
perspective again being a mathematician
he was very concerned about elegance and
simplicity and that's how he saw beauty
in the software systems and yet realized
he was dealing with software systems
that by today's standards you know
somebody in high school would whip out
quickly there's relatively small systems
a few hundred if not a few thousand
lines of code and he had never began to
experience the problems of scale that we
ourselves faced today there was a
contradiction in his life as well to
Turing of course was the man behind the
breaking of the Enigma code the the
German telecommunications code that was
used for a lot of their naval work there
were some poignant stories in that
regard and that his team had actually
broken the Enigma code fairly early on
and yet to expose the fact would have
meant that the Germans probably would
have changed the code and that would
have caused devastating things so there
are a number of circumstances where
they'd gotten in messages from naval
broadcasts they knew that an attack was
going to happen I put upon a particular
convoy and actually did nothing about it
because to do so would expose the code
and in the same time hundreds of people
were killed so difficult thing for him
to deal with and so really his work
shortened the war effort by a couple of
people saying well not a couple a number
of historian
bye-bye several years and yet at the
same time later in his life Turing was
actually condemned by the very country
that he saved Turing was a homosexual
and that wasn't exactly something that
you did in Victorian England or turn of
the century England and through the war
he eventually was was found out if you
will and chemically castrated and he
eventually got off the drugs and said
enough of this and committed suicide so
his light was prematurely ended so his
life was very much a contradiction a
number of things that he did just he was
so far ahead of his time in terms of the
things that he that he had began to
pursue issues of quantum computing for
example far ahead of fineman's work even
the notion of artificial life all of
these things so as I alluded to he had
really spent a lot of time or at least
from a mathematical perspective trying
to understand what we couldn't couldn't
do I've recast this and what I call the
limits of software saying what are the
things that make it difficult or
impossible for us to take a vision and
turn into reality you had a vision to
build the next generation operating
system it didn't just happen overnight
it was painful and difficult than
chaotic what are the things I would ask
you that made it difficult for you turn
that vision of reality let's walk
through a few of these for some domains
the laws of physics intrude I was doing
work with another defense-related
project and they said okay we've got
this global kind of Defense Command
control system and we want to have the
the synchronization of events around the
world to a certain really precise number
and I said well that's really
fascinating but that won't happen in
this universe that that it violates
pretty much everything we know about the
synchronicity of events you just can't
do it to that level of precision yes
cannot you get much Prasad much what was
admitted into the Skip night you can but
the problem is they wanted to go beyond
what the speed of light could even do
for us even with in you know this is the
government they sort of asked for what
they want but they are asking for
synchronization to down to a very very
precise level you simply could not get
that accuracy around the world so I
would see and also the path they were on
the design was just going to be so
literally expensive I said well gee you
have this thing called the GPS system
why don't you get a good enough answer
and that'll do it for you and they said
oh yeah that may be okay so this is an
example of relaxing a particular
constraint that is so overwhelming no
amount of codes going to deal with it
just relaxing a little bit will give you
the opportunity to do some other simpler
solutions nASA has this problem i was
doing some work with one of their
deep-space probes and barry beim tells a
story because it happened to him a few
decades ago and my gosh had happened to
me about three years ago they said okay
here's the thing we're building let's do
a design review this is cool and by the
way we can only write so many lines of
code because because otherwise it will
weigh too much and I said wait a minute
way too much they said well yes it does
because x lines of c translate into y
bits of object code those white bits of
object code have to be blasted into an
prom and there are certain only a
certain number of space qualified
problems that exist in the world and
those problems have weight ergo software
has weight and we can't exceed that we
also know they told me this is
absolutely real I'm not making this
stuff up they also said remember that
computation follows all the normal laws
of thermodynamics so when you compute
you cast off heat and therefore if I'm
doing a deep calculation I may cast off
heat on my computer on board the
spacecraft and I may actually have to
program my spacecraft to rotate when
that happens so I can cool it off and it
doesn't get too hot so heat and weight
are actually things that are limiting
factors for these kinds of devices now
imagine if your Vista team had to worry
about that
who this weighs too much let's that'd be
kind of scary the one project I've been
doing work with where where people have
to deal with relativistic effects are
back to the GPS folks the satellites are
far enough away and they're moving
quickly enough they actually have to
make adjustments in their software for
the fact that there's dilation of time
at that speed next level up deals with
what I call the laws of software and
these are things that David Jurrell has
observed in his delightful book you go
to places like FedEx or or or UPS and
they'll tell you that mathematically we
sort of know that if you have about
tenish packages going to about 10
different cities we can do a brute force
calculation to tell you the optimal
routing of all those packages problem is
in flight in any particular day not
including thanksgiving in christmas
which things go nuts they have around 15
million packages in flight to about
10,000 different destinations that's not
within the cities but that's the major
cities themselves and there simply
aren't enough seconds in the known
universe to be able to calculate that
the optimal routing given the
computational resources we have so what
do you do will you do something
different you apply a neural Nets you
apply some genetic algorithms you do
some exotic things to get a good enough
answer the corollary to that is a
problem of algorithmic breakthroughs
which some domains have to deal with one
all mentioned in particular is the the
computer graphics world in in both games
as well as films so if you look at the
history of algorithmic breakthroughs in
computer graphics the first thing we had
to break through Jim blin and crew kind
of did this was how do I draw a teapot I
mean how do I make that happen you've
seen the classic teapots the next thing
was how do I then make that teapot look
like it did not come from a Barbies no
set IE something other than plastics the
problem of textures the next thing was
issues a reflection and just having you
know the the contributions of all the
things around you so this is where all
the ray tracing algorithms and cool
stuff came to be but then the next
algorithmic breakthrough dealt with
Kenny Matty
where you want to have these things
actually move about and make them look
real the next level a breakthrough dealt
with problems of interesting textures
like water in particular that was really
hard for people to do Digital Domain the
company that did the special effects of
the Titanic they did the special effects
for the day after tomorrow they do the
best water in the business they've got
some great algorithms but prior to their
breakthroughs water looked just not like
water at all but now it looks pretty
real the next algorithmic breakthrough
was the problem of clothing there's a
scene in the type in Titanic where if
you look real close and look at it from
a geeky perspective but she's standing
on the bridge with with Leonardo and
they're you know doing their thing I'm
king of the world thing and she's got a
scarf or red scarf apparently the CEO
Digital Domain told me John Cameron
thought it looked horrible it was a real
scarf but didn't wave right he said okay
so they digitally removed her red scarf
and then put in a computer graphics one
which of course costs them lots and lots
of money to do so but it led them down
the path the building algorithms for
clothing where you really had to build
some really incredible models for the
clothing itself and how does it interact
with bodies how does it deal with a
different kind of textures and there
have been algorithmic breakthroughs to
deal with out the problem people are
dealing with now is kind of represented
here i am a halo they freaked by the way
so I am so waiting for this to come out
but here's a little clip from it
I want you to take a look at what you
don't see in
because this gives me my hailer rush
and what you don't see I mean it's
amazingly photorealistic but you don't
see the faces
this is pointing out is
where this community is
next needs to go our algorithms for
mostly human faces because we as humans
have seen other humans for you know a
few millennium or 6,000 years of you
happen to be a creation is depending
upon whatever it is but we have all
these cues that we know that we've seen
and we don't quite have it right so this
is the next level of algorithmic
breakthrough that we know we need to go
to once we get there then you don't need
actors and actresses or maybe you
neither once but okay there we go there
we go a corollary to this is the problem
of concurrency we talked about this a
little bit earlier this afternoon I've
gone to the to a variety of gaming
companies and they've showed me some
fantastic things you're doing with a
Cell processor which of course is the
basis of the next generation and most
most for the next consoles so you've got
here in an eight-way a symmetric
processor or set of processors and yet
most it will I'd say not most but just
about everybody doesn't know how to
program these things we can do it in
brute force ways to say well audio works
on this chip and you know video on this
one and we you know do AI on this one
but it turns out to leave the cell as a
whole under underutilized so we know
that there is more that can be done and
yet we haven't had a lot of good
breakthroughs and how one does
concurrency at an intimate level and
this is going to be a very real problem
and we're spending time on it if you
guys are spending time on it because
this is the nature of the next
generation of platforms and the average
developer the average developer simply
does not know how to build secure
concurrent distributed systems is this
complex enough as it is now throw eight
processors on them and they're just
going to go ape the next level a problem
as we move up this ladder is the problem
of design most interesting systems that
work generally are stolen from systems
that work in the first place and this is
part of what I'm trying to do in the
looking at software architectures what
is the history of evolution of many of
these because I find that within a
particular domain or anish once the core
architecture has been established and
it's reached
economic viability in that space there's
often very little variation from that
point there on largely because it's good
enough and the economic forces are such
that it's impossible to change unless
you blow up the business and start over
again this is probably why folks like
Google or a little bit annoying because
they had it easy they had no legacy to
worry about now it'll be fun to watch
them in about ten years when they
finally grow up in fact i'll tell you
the story i do now and please don't take
this wrong but the way I characterize
you guys versus IBM versus Google as is
IBM is a company that's gone through a
near-death experience during the 90s IBM
almost blew apart and we've gone to the
other side and we're stronger and wiser
for it you guys are going through a
midlife crisis that's the way I'd
characterize it that you're you're in a
great place and yet you know your
management is changing out from you
you've sort of you know lost a little of
the buzz and you sort of wonder a man
should I've gotten that sports car or
you know those kind of things what do I
do next Google is a company that needs
adult supervision is the way I'd
characterize it that if I were 20
something with a dog and a futon they'd
be a fun place to work but you know
they're going to go through the same
growth phase you have been as well as
IBM has been so their problem is they're
just making too much money and it hides
a lot of the evils that are going on
there again that's my opinion on IBM's
so for many systems then we know how to
build them largely because we built them
before this is why i am so enamored of
the work that's gone on design patterns
i would claim then in the last 10 years
or so the most important development in
software engineering has been the ideas
of design patterns and patterns that are
higher than that because they give us an
opportunity a language of expression
that transcends individual lines of code
and individual classes indeed as i go in
and do these archaeological digs I'll go
in and spend time with the architects
themselves and they have the design
patterns in their head but most of them
don't have the
language or design patterns so they will
say I've done this in this and I'll say
oh it's this kind of pattern and they'll
say well I've never heard it like that
but that's what it is so many of these
patterns are part of their tribal memory
and they're simply unnamed and therefore
part of the archaeological digging
process is to give name to these things
that they already have and that's
valuable because insofar as we can name
these things and the people that go on
beyond them will be able to continue to
grow that system in ways that fit the
intellectual integrity of the original
system that's why if you look at the
ebays and the Amazons and the e trade's
of the world you will see distinct
phases of about for each of these about
four or five architectural epochs in
which they built something it sort of
reached its limits they had to blow it
apart and start over again the first
version of ebay of course was a whole
bunch of i think it was PHP scripts
because the guy had a girlfriend and he
wanted to sell she wanted to sell her
Pez dispensers online so we whip
something together very quickly that
obviously wasn't in a scale ebay today
handles about a what are they telling me
a million new auction items per day and
so this is an amazing system yet they're
at a point where they can't blow it up
anymore they're at a point where they
have a continuously running system that
they can never turn off and so they have
a problem of architectural
transformation keeping this thing up and
running and yet changing it out from
under them now with your operating
systems like you have the opportunity
for you know kind of controlling things
and you can kind of blow things up and
start over but their reaches a point of
diminishing returns where you get tired
and your customers get tired of things
being blown up the next level is is is
more and more on the social side of
things I've got these systems of scale
how then do I organize my teams so that
they can build these things this is the
problem of the social engineering of the
teams themselves it no longer is
possible even the gaming world to get a
handful of people together and go build
something wonderful and have a
world-class world-class operation just
not going to happen you may get to your
IPO and then go on but then the rest of
the world's going to be
happy with you but to really build
systems of enduring value requires a
focus upon the organization's themselves
there's a delightful book by Jim Killeen
and Harrison titled organizational
patterns of agile development and in it
he takes a look at what hyper productive
teams tend to look like how do they
organize themselves in terms of their
skill set and I've seen the things that
Jim is seen over and over again from a
number of organizations the next few I'm
going to zip through because they're
kind of technically interesting and they
start addressing a lot of the human side
of things Barry bayman his work on
costing models and we don't in my
experience we don't do a lot of formal
costing models but his kokomo to work
observes has very interesting
observation for me he observes that the
performance of any software project is a
factor of these four main things
complexity raised to the power process
time the team's times the tools the
important thing here is that mrs. in the
order of importance that the greater the
complexity of a system the greater
impact it's going to have upon its
performance in a negative way and
furthermore anything we can do to reduce
complexity will have tremendous impact
upon our performance how do we do that
well the best way to reduce the risk of
your software systems is to not write
any software at all obviously and that's
one of the things that's fueling a lot
of the work and service-oriented
architectures because it means
ineffective its message passing for
God's sake it's the same kind of stuff
just through a different kind of medium
but it allows us to reuse systems in
ways and the granularity that we could
not have in the past it's also the case
that a bad process and amplify
complexity and a good process can dampen
complexity let me skip over those so if
you were to remember one thing from what
I've said thus far I hope it's this that
software development has been it is and
it will remain fundamentally hard and
that's part of the excitement of being
in this field because it's not going to
get an easier the things that people are
asking of us are are more and more
demanding and that complexity is simply
not going to go away that being said
there are some things that we are pretty
certain we know and some things we think
we know and some things that we know we
don't know it sounds a little like
Rumsfeld but frightening but here are
some things that I think we know we know
in the end the fundamentals never go out
of style that in heat of battle you may
throw some of these things out you've
got to get our particular release out
you've got to do it but in so far is
your process allows you to go back and
spend some time on these fundamentals to
make things simpler to go off and
refactor then you're going to be in the
right place one of those fundamentals
focusing upon crisp abstractions having
a good separation of concerns having a
balanced distribution responsibilities
in effect having beautiful software
there is always economic value in so
doing in the long term although it may
not be so in the short term and the
fourth one is not on this list but I see
among two or three really productive
organizations around the world and
that's a focus upon simplicity I run
across a few projects we're literally
and I'm not talking Google here I'm
talking some others in the valley where
they will spend about ten percent of
their development budget to
intentionally go off and refactor and
simplify from release release their
development staff has convinced their
highest levels of management that there
is tremendous economic value in so doing
and they've got a really good long-term
process along a long-term perspective
some things we pretty much know we know
you know reuse in my mind is kind of a
solved problem in the sense that reuse
of individual lines of code has proven
itself to be economically uninteresting
it's practical but interesting but but
it doesn't have much impact so we I
don't care about that much anymore it's
really reused at the level of design
patterns and up that we see economically
interesting reuse and reuse of systems
as a whole and this may be a little bit
controversial but I would claim also
that I'm seeing a plateau in languages
and if you take a look at most of the
interesting language research going on
we're polishing doorknobs and we're
doing some interesting things to make
certain parts of it easier but by and
large I don't see any any any state
changes and what language stuff is doing
right now now I think there are some
opportunities especially in the area of
concurrency in the areas of verification
as we talked about with some of your
folks today the latter is a little bit
more polishing as opposed to being a
fundamental shift but I think there were
right for some fundamental shifts
dealing with truly concurrent kind of
languages now a couple of things here
before I open it up for questions so I
wanted to spend a little bit of time on
the architecture project I'm up to there
are things like togaf and dodeth and
motive and the Zachman framework and a
whole bunch of things where people have
said if I want to describe a systems
architecture here's how I do it when I
first approached the Computer History
Museum and said you ought to do the
software stuff they said oh we already
have a museum quality display showing
software architecture I'd love to see it
happen to be one of Photoshop and so
they had this beautiful display this
black onyx kind of thing pictures of the
developers and the way they represented
the software was they had a box of
Photoshop and I suggested them politely
there's probably a little more you can
do and so how then can I expose the
beauty of software so those can see it
in civil engineering we see the beauty
of systems by the physically built thing
itself but we in our world we don't have
those kind of things so we have to look
on the inside I've been mostly inspired
by the work of philippe christian in his
so-called 4+1 model view which observes
that if you want to look at the essence
of a systems architecture there are at
least five use you need to take a look
at two of them are conceptual they deal
with the vocabulary of the problem space
and control structures two of them are
physical they deal with things like your
component architecture and how those
things you're deployed around the world
and then what ties it all together are
based of the use cases that run this
kind of thing so as I'm doing my
archeological digs in effect I am
creating an instance of this for every
one of the systems I look at
some people collect stamps I collect
architectures so if you go to my site
and there's the Earl for it there I've
collected about while getting close to
200 different architectures of different
systems now a caveat to offer here these
are diagrams written by the architects
themselves and they represent only one
particular view of a systems
architecture so this happens to be the
architecture of the canadian air traffic
control system i was involved with
hughes when they bid against IBM for the
US air traffic control system IBM
eventually won it and this is a great
example in looking at what the FAA and
IBM did about how really to spend a few
billion dollars in screw up it was it
was just a disaster in so many ways I
remember being introduced to the project
early on after they'd won the bid they
say oh we're so proud we won this and
we're so happy we built this new build
these two new buildings this one for our
analyst and this one for our developers
and I suggested that was really a stupid
thing to do and you could just see the
memo wars that we're going to go on from
there Hughes lost that bid and they went
up to Canada and wanted and they were
actually successful to the point we're
actually trying to sell this back to the
US and other places around the world and
I think one of the reasons they were
successful is because they had they see
a team of two architects who are in
charge of the intellectual integrity of
the system they built this thing in an
incremental iterative way now this is a
really crappy architecture diagram
because it just says well it's bunch of
boxes and it's layered well that doesn't
tell me much the real beauty of this
comes in when you begin to look at the
patterns that animated and that's why
pattern languages are so important to me
one of the patterns that come out of
this if you study the architecture is
that they've got this notion of a mobile
object so I've got this object called a
flight which which is an isomorphic with
a physical flight itself and is that
physical aircraft moves from place to
place the software object also moves
from air traffic control center to
center it has the nice side effect that
if an air traffic control center goes
down for whatever reason there are
automatic ways of replicating that state
so it goes elsewhere in
never disappears so in order to
understand the canadian air traffic
control system you don't have to just
understand the structure which is
uninteresting you have to understand the
dynamics of the patterns that lie within
it this is the architecture of a future
combat system being built for the army
and it's sort of your classic you know
kind of how would I describe this is a
classic command and control architecture
but they made the design decision to put
a bus in the middle a message bus they
chose korba which in retrospect was
probably a profoundly stupid thing but
but the reason they chose a bus and all
is that in their domain you've got all
these things on the outside and people
shoot at you and blow them up and so
things come and go which is is really a
mess and so what can you do to build a
relatively survivable system and the
answer is you have a bus upon which that
works of course you now change the
single point of failure but but you can
deal with that in other ways if you look
at the history of games they've changed
radically over the years this comes from
an ACM article if you look at some of
the games from around 94 so remember we
had very very limited computational
resources so most of the software was
basically serving up polygons to some
graphic processor and you had very few
cycles for AI or things like that next
generation up well it's more complex
therefore it must be more interesting
but we now had the computational cycles
to go off and do some component ization
of these systems in fact it's to the
point where you had third parties come
in and they were able to build
components for you you can go to havoc
calm by a physics engine you can buy
terrain mapping engines all sorts of
things that reduces the the the cost of
entry for the many of these
organizations it's amazing what you can
do in learning about architectures by
setting patents and papers so one of
larry's early papers was written while
he was at stanford on the architecture
what was to become google and this is a
curious diagram because it's a
combination of both software and
hardware the barrels are obviously the
individual servers the ellipse like
things are mostly the software pieces if
you look at google's architecture today
hasn't changed a whole heck of a lot
except in so far they're about 10,000 or
more of these at each one of the sites i
think if you take a G if you take an
infrared map of the world and look for
the hot spots that's where you find the
Google server sites which is why they're
building the next ones by rivers and the
like Google actually has a very
simplifying assumption they can make
which is there's no such thing as a
perfect search is a good enough search
and they'll assume that if you don't
quite like the search you'll just try it
again and refine it and so that's what
simplified their problem for them
compare that to the problem that an ebay
might have or a visa might have where
you can't have an imprecisely answer you
have to have a very precise answer and
that means that this architecture is not
certainly suitable to those kinds of
domains this is the architecture of the
Pathfinder up on Mars right now and
what's interesting about this let's see
the boxes are Hardware this the ellipse
shapes are our software what's
interesting about this one it's more of
a network kind of architecture than what
you saw and the layered architecture is
elsewhere in fact it the real core of
this comes into the the design patterns
behind it if you look at the control
structures for this system it is a time
driven control structure as opposed to
an event driven through the structure
here's how a typical mission will work
I'm up there on Mars have got these
stereoscopic cameras and on a daily
basis the rover is positioned and such
that it will send an image of all that
it sees around there and they're
downloaded at the rate of about ten bod
I mean you're a long way away and
basically it's like having a cell phone
on Mars and listening to that signal
it's a little bit noisy so you get us
you get these pictures somebody on the
ground then says wow that's a really
interesting purple thing over there with
antennas let's go to it and so what
they'll then do the mission controller
will then say all right rover I want you
to go there and that's all it has to do
because the rover then has enough
intelligence on board to be able to plot
a path from where it is to that point
hopefully without falling into a hole or
hitting a rock and so it's semi
autonomous navigation in that regard and
the
it's control structures are built our
that you divide the world up into time
and certain things happen within one
frame and other things in another frame
and other things in another frame and if
there's an overrun then you simply slip
it to the next frame in its notion of
subframes so there is more
predictability in what happens than what
I get and say a web centric system baby
and I want to talk about these okay last
thing I'm going to mention here's sort
of the current state that I see the
world in the average application is
continuously evolving meaning we can
never really shut it off again the
average interesting one tends to be
connected distributed concurrent has to
be multilingual and multi-platform has
to be secure has to be relatively
autonomic and most systems actually
these days are not just individual
systems but they're more so systems of
systems this is why messaging kind of
architectures are dominating again and I
say again because these are not new
things by any means service-oriented
architectures is just message passing
recasts in a different kind of mechanism
but ultimately it gets back to message
passing itself that's a typical system
where I see is going and I think I'm
wildly off here in terms of the decades
that the coming decades are one of
increasing transparency what I mean by
that is we are building systems that
increasingly are finding themselves in
the interstitial spaces of the world and
so we're building stuff that more and
more people who care nothing about
software are going to be be using and
that's incredible responsibility for us
the next generation I think is a time of
total dependence for us as people
working in this civilization the idea of
being in a place where i have no
software that's touching me will be
utterly inconceivable and it'll be hard
to get away from from non-software
places you'll probably see you know
resorts where people say oh there's no
software here how exciting totally retro
and the decade beyond that I could call
one of the rise of the machines and not
sort of in the big mainframe sense but
here's what Telegraph's this for me
look at Japan for a moment Japan is a
place where you have a curious
demographic situation happening the
population is actually shrinking there
are fewer Japanese predictor than their
work and the skewing of the elderly
Japanese is such that we have fewer
younger Japanese folks to take care of
the elderly so how do you deal with that
well one way is why not having why not
have semi-autonomous things it can help
those older folks climb stairs or be
companions for them you know pets that
don't poop that kind of thing and so
that's why I Honda and Sony and well
just about everybody every one of the
interesting companies inside Japan is
spending a lot of money these days on
humanoid like robotics and so I think
we're going to you know that's going to
come into our society as well too just
my prediction here's what frightens me
the most well not frightens but excites
me no matter what prediction you can
have for the future however outlandish
it might be it all depends upon software
that we have not yet written now it may
be software you've written in your
children are debugging but but but
there's still a lot of software out
there to be written and that's why I
consider it to be an incredible
privilege to be a software developer
because what we are doing bit by bit is
changing the world and yet at the same
time it is an incredible responsibility
because what we are doing is changing
the world in very very subtle ways so
there you have it I have time for 25
minutes of questions sure thang
yes way in the back archaeology
exercises have you seen best practices
around the reporting tribal knowledge i
have i have seen ways that are better
than others are you sure you want to
shut down your computer now I thought I
thought she was going to answer it for
me Wow so where was I I have seen better
practices let me give you the range of
practices that I've seen at the best end
i have seen organizations that have
discovered or realize that they have
lost control of their architecture so
they're actually spending time with an
archaeological dig to intentionally go
off and document the architecture they
have I was recently with the the CIO of
the state of New Jersey and they said
they were frightened because if you look
at the demographics of their development
staff they have a lot of really young
people they have a lot of old people not
old people people who are near
retirement age and they are incredibly
frightened those people are going to
retire and there's so much knowledge
they have it'll be utterly lost so
they're contemplating such a project and
we're trying to advise them on so doing
other practices I've seen which is
related to some of the collaboration
stuff I've done are simply the
preservation of wikis that people have
to force design discussions about
certain things another thing I've seen
which sort of popped up in the Xerox
PARC era that still I see people do a
lot of stuff happens on whiteboards take
a digital picture of those whiteboards
and put it on a website for your project
so those kind of simple practices seem
to work well there's not a single
organization i've encountered that does
it really well yet except the one that i
mentioned that i know is doing some
archaeological digs there maybe your two
or three of those right now most of them
still keep it in tribal memory
unfortunately
what do they choose to write down the
good ones tend to write down the
following three sets of things what are
the major design decisions what's the
rationale for those design decisions so
we don't go back over them again and
then lastly the major design patterns
that structure the system itself if
they've done that then you probably
extracted this seventy percent solution
from those folks and I find that I have
to go back to the the architects
themselves to get this information I was
doing an archaeological dig for Eclipse
reasonable thing to do and as I study
the documentation I realized there
exists lots of detailed design
documentation for certain specific nasty
pieces of Eclipse and at the other end
of the spectrum there are lots of
PowerPoint slides and there's nothing in
between whatsoever so in order to really
understand the architecture I've had to
go to Erich gamma and John Wigan and
others to say tell me what was in your
head and it's in their head but we're
already starting to see some degree of
architectural degeneration because these
guys are no longer on the eclipse
project and there are people who are
continuing to maintain eclipse and yet
they don't have what's in John and
Eric's head so that's what I'm trying to
capture for them those three things seem
to be relevant now if you go to my site
you'll also see that I have a metamodel
for the other stuff that I'm collecting
that in addition to those three things
I'm doing it against the four plus one
model view so the patterns are very
important I'm also collecting a lot of
the meta information the team size the
team structure the tools that were used
and this the the forces upon the system
at the time because I'm convinced and I
don't have enough empirical evidence to
suggest this that certain kind of forces
will warp you to a particular
architecture versus another and I want
to document the way it was because if I
relax a certain force then that may lead
me to change my architecture in certain
ways and sounds simply trying to collect
that as well great question yes
I heard it said and some papers in the
past of software is different
and looking at the complexity of
physical systems do you think that's
true or is that and no offense to the
others here it seems to be an excuse for
lazy engineering in some cases well in
fact you know how would I say this we as
an industry have been have enabled we've
been enabler 'he's in the sense that we
have kept increasing the computational
resources at people's disposal we've
allowed developers to become sloppy
because they're simply not constrained
by things i did a bra i did a post on my
blog recently about the the coming
constraints of heat that heat and power
that most of us as we think about
scaling up stuff we don't think about
the cost of energy for us for our
devices and yet that's starting to
become a force that weighs upon us which
requires us to become less sloppy so to
go back to your initial issue which I
actually forgot was really fascinating
one though it it software different and
the answer i would offer is yes it is
because physical systems unless you're
at the quantum level tend to be
continuous whereas software systems are
not necessarily continuous and there is
this explosion of of state combinations
such that a minor change in one place
may cause a discontinuous behavior
another that i simply can't model at all
so that's why I think software is
different in that sense and which makes
it so much more difficult for us what do
you think who knows i think it is
difficult and also not just because of
that biz just because of the sheer size
of the things we have to worry about we
are outstripping our ability to know how
to manage developments that involve tens
of millions of lines of code and that's
becoming a typical number for many
economically interesting systems we just
are beyond our blocking and tackling
there yes way in the back
so four digs what would he see totaling
way average
we've been here 25 is a good business
what you think you will do now based on
way to the system so let me replay that
back what you're asking me is knowing
what I know now what do I think this is
going to do for us five or so years from
now wow how am I thinking has changed
he's got it yeah my thinking has changed
quite a bit because you know there was a
time in my youth where I thought ADA was
the way God intended us to program and
actually you know I think perhaps one of
the there are many shifts but I think
one of the biggest shifts I've had in
the recent years is that the problem is
no longer one of language but it's it's
an issue of design and organization
those are the two places that kill most
projects in their success and so this is
maybe why the whole language area has
reached some degree of plateau that
there may be some interesting things
there may be some breakthroughs I don't
see them happening immediately I don't
see any places for that because the real
hard problems are at levels far above
languages and that that's been a shift
in my thinking that I thought it was
more of a language issue and I think
it's it's not as much as it was I've
been disappointed in the whole modeling
side of things I've disappointed in this
is my personal opinion not that of
anybody else but I've been disappointed
somewhat in the direction you know Mel
tude has headed because there have been
a number of folks that wanted to turn
the UML into a programming language
which I thought was really stupid and I
always envisioned the UML and any
modeling language for that for that
matter to simply be a language to reason
about systems so I tend to use a very
light weight part of the UML i use maybe
twenty percent of it and that's good
enough for me to capture what i want to
do an architectural perspective anything
else is a level of precision where the
cost of that level of precision
overwhelms the value of it so that's
another thing i've learned that we may
be outreach to ourselves and the
modeling side not to say the modeling
not important
the other thing I think I've learned in
this process is probably how much we we
don't know my gosh it frightens me to
see the systems we built and I go into
places where these companies are my
absolute heroes they've built some
wonderful things I go inside and I
realize wow this is pretty but ugly
stuff you build and it's amazing that it
still runs and works and so the level of
immaturity of many of these large
systems absolutely is blowing me away
truly has that frightens me somewhat
good questions yes there was a question
up here you 70 I essentially a bit
skeptical about the issue the inputs of
languages but also said that so many
architecture so many presence of systems
is actually just in the head yes so in a
way what were completely suggest you
having more research on languages over
patterns or what kind of representation
of architectures and see see I think
that's one of the areas of unknown in an
unknown area in an area where we can do
continuing innovation if you look at the
work that the folks at CMU have done and
the sei have done and others in the
world in terms of architectural
representation we don't have any you
know there are some good ideas but
nothing's really caught hold entirely we
have things like the UML we have various
kinds of frameworks that allow people to
describe architectures but i'm not sure
we as a community have looked at enough
different architectures and simply try
to describe them to know if we have the
right languages for them yet and i'm not
talking necessarily purely textual
languages or purely graphical languages
but i think something that works at a
level of abstraction that's appropriate
for a system now i'm trying i'm using
uml i'm using the four plus one model
view because it appears to be adequate
for the systems i've looked at thus far
honest you don't know if it's going to
scale the systems of systems i'm looking
at things like the federal government's
deadline advantage system which is the
software used to handle the resolution
of all bond trading in the world and i'm
kind of little stymied as to whether or
not i can represent that and yet people
need to because there are a bunch of
architects trying to keep this thing
alive so i just don't know enough yet i
think one of the other things i learned
is when we built models and built
modeling languages we had a bit of
hutzpah and we said well we're going to
devise the modeling language and will
apply it to the world well I think
that's bad science actually that
probably the right thing we should do
which is what I'm trying to make amends
for right now is to be a little bit more
I guess inductive is the right word
looking at existing systems trying to
document them and seeing what we can
learn from those specifics and find the
generalities in the past we've done a
lot of generalities and apply them to
specifics so I'm doing penance and
trying to do the reverse so I think the
short answer to your question is I think
there is work to be done in the language
space in the area of language of
languages that model are
textures we just don't know enough how
to do that in the other place is
languages to support massive intimate
concurrency what i mean by intimate
concurrency is closely coupled
processors on a single slab of silicon
we just don't have the right means of
expression to help people do that well
and I don't know if it's a language I
don't know if it's patterns I don't know
if it's libraries just don't know enough
in the meantime we'll muddle through for
the next generation and do stuff good
question anything from this side yes
when career when you show me
architecture of this salsas gets it well
this looks nice but it doesn't really
matter because what really matters is
this behavioral object yeah that's kind
of indicative of how many experience
that I have it's hard as its broad
behavior of systems especially when
they're
yes is there something that you do about
that in the archive or any locations
that people should use could that I just
had I begin with the I Triple E standard
portion 72 which gives me some
approaches to to representing
architectures where that standard falls
short is it it says different views are
important but it doesn't tell you what
views there are so that's why I've
chosen then the five views that I talked
about and one of those views the process
view is where I capture control
structure kinds of things and I do so in
the form of patterns so if you go to my
site you'll learn that I've I've
cataloged about 2,000 design patterns
that people have already documented in
the literature so as I do these digs
what I'm trying to do is to say well the
architects describe this but boy it
smells an awful lot like this pattern
and so I'm trying to at least name those
things in other cases I will discover
they have a pattern that simply nobody
is documented before so for each one of
the systems I'm documenting for like the
process view I will have a basic
description of what the control flows
are the tasks can process kinds of
decisions but then also an enumeration
of the design patterns that animate that
part of the system and that's basically
what I'm trying to document now that
assumes that you know what those design
patterns are because if you don't then
it's not going to help you understand
the architecture but my gut says it
across the hundred systems i've looked
at which is really the whole spectrum of
many kinds of computable systems they're
probably two dozen different truly
different architectures that exist out
there i don't think there any more than
that and i hope in the end to be able to
name those kinds of things so there's
work to be done but I think it does come
back to the notion of capturing the
design patterns
representin structure okay well remember
design patterns have both a structural
as well as a behavioral element to them
so that they'll have the structure of
the the Society of classes that interact
with one another but then also something
some specification of the the temporal
complete or partial ordering of their
interaction so that's why it's wrapped
up in design patterns for me seven in
the middle yes full of just a blast
media here I always appreciate getting
perspectives on people yeah yeah in
other words I'm old yes okay we have an
industry that tends to burn people out
of the young age yes some be kind of her
like we don't have the Wisel tonight to
say oh yeah some 30 years ago yeah okay
so if you're working on a project yeah
where the information is in games has
yeah and you take to the next level yeah
you need to get a written down yeah but
we have this culture of
you know so people will keep things in
their heads as kind of jobs right right
sorry I mean that's kind of a big elton
juror it is it is how can you get
something to move to the next level when
there's almost like a maturity that you
know what you have to trust it you're
not gonna write everything down and then
she have to work off to some other group
right I don't have a good answer for you
on that one I wish I did I I hope that
the work I'm doing with the Computer
History Museum and the architecture work
itself is a beginning step to change the
culture that preserving this stuff is
relevant there will always be the the
societal things you described it I
actually have my value because of the
knowledge that I uniquely have and
therefore my net worth is is is mented
by the fact people have to come to me so
there's both very realistic economic
benefit as well as egotistical benefit
from doing so that's the nature of the
human spirit it's not going to change
although in so far is that is true of
your senior architects that's
economically devastating for the
business it'll happen in the small it's
going to happen in the small for the
generations that come that's the nature
of human nature but I hope we can change
the culture at least from the
architectural perspective didn't also
happen to be this way in civil
engineering if you study the works of a
true vyas and some of the really early
architects the same phenomena you
described existed around then too I mean
my gosh consider some of the things that
I've read among the Egyptian architects
the the kingwood would kill the
architects because he was afraid that
their knowledge would be spread out to
other places now I hope we don't quite
get to that point
alright all you people who develop vista
lineup this would be a very bad thing so
it was actually worse back then and you
know we kind of got over that to the
point now we actually celebrate the
architects of buildings there's a book
coming out from a Tim O'Reilly series
called beautiful code in which they've
gone off and and actually talked to
people and senior developers and said
show me an example of some beautiful
code and talk about it so we're starting
to change that culture of the
celebration of the artifacts themselves
and I think that's that's a good thing
so you know human nature the way it is
that's going to happen so we'll change
it bit by bit maybe time for two more
questions you and you and intentional
programming well I was actually hoping
to visit Charles while he was out while
I was out here Charles wrote me and he's
in Europe now I guess he's still getting
used to gravity but here's my personal
opinion about it and I'm going to expand
that to talk to you about
aspect-oriented programming as well I
thought the whole notion of where that
community was headed a few years ago was
really cool and fundamental but the alp
community in particular in my mind
really got just stuck in the weeds but
they are worried about programmatic
transformations for things that were
economically uninteresting I wanted them
to look at aspects like security as an
aspect and nobody seemed to be climbing
up to that level so I do believe that
there are cross-cutting concerns that
impact many interesting systems I do
believe that the aspect community has
utterly failed to solve anything in that
space I think Charles in his company are
doing some fascinating things I wish him
well if I had a billion dollars to go up
and spend it might be fun to start a
company like that as well too I don't
know about its economic viability
largely because of the embedded you know
stuff that people already have and so
it's hard to say if that the work he is
doing will make a fundamental change I
don't know I have a very similar opinion
with semantic web stuff as well too I've
been on one of the debu 3c committees
dealing with
al and the like and alas they're a bunch
of academics it sort of seemed to take
over that work and well this is cool
that I can now represent any conceivable
form of knowledge in any human or alien
language or whatever I keep telling them
it's just software and so I don't really
want to be able to go to the nth
possible level get me something good
enough so I fear that that's been over
engineered somewhat we'll see last
question and I may even have time for an
answer yes you're the man so um how can
to play along one day so I want to say
something you may disagree I'll I hate
it when people agree with me it gets
really boring so say something
controversial like there's spinach
between your teeth or whatever I don't
insult me do whatever yes let's hear the
language reaching a plight oh yes it's
probably not the really interesting
except for in the case of patterns i
think it's may be premature in sissu we
don't know at least i don't know how to
program things like robots robotic
systems and i think
intimate concurrency parallelize
re-imagining yes it is my example that
we talk about physical systems yes can
go a lot more than the internet
parallelize gifts and I looked at the
high school students programmi robust so
to get the programming interface it's
asking myself is it abstraction
interface a language and so maybe my
discriminant is pointless it really
wants to what what we don't know so the
blood would we have are good for solving
the problems we know maybe what we don't
know is what's going to be the problem
that's their interest right which is why
you know we're going to be busy and
having fun for the next several
generations because they're a lot of
things we know we don't know how to do
and we don't even know we don't know how
to do we don't even know we don't know
we don't how to do and all of a sudden
I'm going to recursive loop here you can
touch upon a couple of things on a
number of things but to i'd like to make
mention of on the robotic side it turns
out that there are emerging some common
architectures that we see there i met
with the sony team that does their
asthma robot and I was utterly surprised
to discover that as mo is built upon an
open source framework it was the same
open source framework used for the
little lobby OH dog and so there's
amazing commonality there the the
architecture that appears to be emerging
in those semi-autonomous kinds of things
is what Rodney Brooks speaks of as a sub
sumption architecture and so we actually
are beginning to see names for these
kinds of things and that's that's an
encouraging sign you talk about
education at the at the high school
level I volunteered at our local high
school a few times largely because at
the urgings of one of my god children
she pointed out this poor instructor is
just so lost and her students know so
much more than she does please help her
I came in and it was was absolutely you
know annoyed to discover that the
students who thought they were experts
basically what they were able to do is
they could put together some simple web
sites they knew how to install the
latest patches from you guys and and
they could do some simple programming
and visual basic or whatever
then they were very proud of this as
they should be but none of them had
really been exposed to beauty scale and
ideas of building good abstractions now
all these folks in this particular class
they were so enamored about games they
were so proud of the things they built I
said hmm let's look at some real games
turns out the source code for Doom is
open source so I downloaded it and I
said let's do a walk-through they'd
never looked at real industrial source
code and the first reaction was oh it's
so big and their next reaction was oh
it's so ugly in places and the third
reaction was how do you really
understand this and so I think it was
eye-opening for them to realize there
are problems of scale and beauty that
they haven't been exposed to at that
level earlier this year I had the
pleasure of giving a keynote address at
the ACM conference for computer science
educators and actually I gave a
variation of this one and one of the
questions I asked their instructor the
instructors were out there how many of
you have reading courses they had no
idea what i was saying well if you're
going to study English Lit you study all
the literature of other great writers
how many of you study the other great
software writers in the world and nobody
raised their hands so I said well here's
an idea why don't you go get some good
code and have your students read it and
critique it so they can get an idea of
what's really out there and what's good
and what's bad so there's still a lot of
work to be done I think there are some
noble people trying to do some good
things what scares me is that the number
of high school students who are
interested in programming still seems to
be plummeting especially the number of
women who care about programming is
plummeting that's why what CMU is doing
with the programming system called Alice
looks really cool so there's hope but we
need to inspire that generation that
programming is fun and we have a ways to
go thank you all very much revenue
you